I am welcome to this breakout session on
cloud Identity and Access Management and
today I'm going to focus on how to
manage your cloud policies efficiently
and at scale so in this session I'm
breaking it out into four pieces we're
going to start with the core concept of
cloud I am what it means and what we do
secondly we're going to have a deep dive
into a bunch of best practices how do
you actually manage at scale third we
have a customer story from Credit Karma
coming up a stage mat explaining how
they manage their cloud resources and
last we have a super-secret not yet
launch feature that you're getting a
sneak peek so take a step back and what
is cloud I am what do we do we answer
the question who can take what action on
which resource there's other policies in
cloud which people sometimes get
confused and think that oh it's this
identity no it's not so old policies
specifically are which configurations
you can have another example is quotas
which is how much money can you spend
how much have a spend where do we who
pays the bill right for this resource so
the first we doing the deep dive into
the core concept of cloud I am cloud I
am provides a fine-grained access
control and we do that in multiple
dimensions and some things I'm going to
talk to you today about is appropriate
if you're a garage you start up or you
just a happy student other things are
focused on large-scale deployments
so we start with core core concepts
permissions everything in iron is based
on iron permissions they have a special
structure they start with a service name
followed by the resource type and then
the verb or the action you can take on
this resource let's take an example
storage dot packets dot crate it's
obvious by the name that these controls
who can create buckets there's two
others that are very common to actions
and they did get iron policy and set I
am policy they exist for every resource
type and I know I'm biased but in my
mind these are the most important
permissions because these are the
permissions that allow you to grant more
permissions to other people or to
yourself so we'll get back to that in
later slides but remember these are
powerful of course creating or updating
a bucket could also be critical if you
have something secret in that bucket
however the set iron policy because it
allows you to grant all new policies is
order magnitude more powerful so let's
take it from the beginning an API is
called say we want to call compute
engine with to get an instance you call
it it will be translated from the on the
back end to check against I am to see do
you have this permission in this
specific case we're going to check if
you have the compute instance get
permission on instance number one if you
do you will get the data you asked for
if you don't you will get an access
denied so that is the simple API now
let's make it more fun other API is take
a lot of different variables in this
case
we're going to one API call comes in to
compute engine it's going to translate
into four different permission checks on
different resource types and for this
API call to be successful you need to
have all four permissions on those
resource types or this API call will
fail so now some of you are in the
audience things like a permissions I
don't deal with permission I've used I
am before I only care about the roles
and to some degree you're correct roles
is the abstraction we use to grouping
permissions together so you can think
about this as performing certain tasks
or certain workflows that permissions
belong together because it allows a user
to accomplish a set of tasks or
workflows so we have actually three
different types of roles in Aion we have
primitive roles which we have they're
the very easy to use
we actually don't recommend that you use
this in production these are very very
powerful and it makes it very easy to
get started again if your student or you
just tinkering feel free to use this if
you're working for a large bank or
something like that please don't use
this instead you should use predefined
roles they are narrower they group
things normally band / service and
there's several several hundreds of
these predefined roles that Google have
defined that we think that all these
belong together this accomplish certain
tasks there is a few patterns there that
basically every service have an admin
and a viewer of a predefined role
there's many specialized roles as well
but could also be that your specific use
case calls for something much
specialized we call that custom roles
custom roles allow you to combine any
permissions together and create any
thing you want and say for me for my use
case I have these workflow and I need my
users to have this set of permissions
because to me they go together maybe not
go together for all of you but for your
specific use case they make sense custom
roles while they can be used for
anything there's three very common use
cases is to combine role you look at the
predefined roles that we have worked
that different teams have worked hard to
create and say oh I like these two roles
and I'm always granting them at the same
time let's combine them right any other
one is like hey I like this role but it
has this powerful permission I don't
like let's remove it or you say this
role has everything I need but this one
permission and you can add it so these
are the most common use cases however
you can combine anything you want so now
we talked about the permissions and the
roles and now we need to bind these two
users we call these bindings obvious
name right and you can bind it to an
individual user or to a group of users
that group can also be a group of a
group of a group nested and everyone in
the whole chain of those groups are
going to be granted right the third type
is a service account and we're going to
come back to that later slides services
account
is basically an identity of a service or
a robot and all of these bindings can
combine be combined so you in Van policy
have multiple bindings with multiple
different roles for multiple different
people and that when you combine all of
those you have a policy so for you that
like Jason this is my favorite example
so you can actually write this and use
command line API and in this specific
example we grant the compute instance
admin role to two users to a user that
is Mike and a group that is the admins
we say this is my powerful role and I
very selective on who I grant this to i
have another role that is less powerful
computer I can grant them to everyone in
my domain or I can grant them to a
specific service account so we have not
talked about our permissions and how we
combined into roles of a bind them to
users our members and now we talk about
a hierarchy so all of these can be
granted in hierarchy and this is a core
core to how Google do identity access
management you can grant these policies
literally anywhere in your resource
hierarchy if you start and granting
something in the org level super high up
in your hierarchy it will be very
powerful the higher up the more powerful
because the permissions is inherited odd
so everyone in your work every resource
that is ever created would be affected
by this policy versus if you do the
other extreme
put a policy on the individual resource
now only that resource will be granted
that specific role that is also not the
best practice because also you might be
successful one day and end up having
millions and millions and millions of
these resources and now you have
millions and millions of policies to
manage so the best practice is to think
about how you in your organization words
what makes sense and I'm going to come
back in the best practice and do a
couple of deep dives in exactly why we
use the Harkey and how we recommend
reason about it I told you I was going
to come back to service accounts so
think about service account as the
identity of one service and that is best
practice that this service account
should take the identity of a specific
service you have his service account can
manage and be the identical multiple
virtual machines you can a multiple
service accounts inside the same project
and these can be granted any other role
so they can act on other project and on
other resources so in this example here
you see that this service account acts
on packets in other projects and that's
totally fine and you can say one service
count access one bucket and my other
service account access my other bucket
and this is where people sometimes get
slightly confused I had to meet and that
is that this service account they are
both an identity by themselves and a
resource which means that you as a user
can grant access to the service account
themselves we and the service account is
an identity so there's one powerful
permission especially that I'm going to
come back
- as it relates to service count that is
very very powerful so just save that for
now now we're going into our second part
the best practices so say that you're
starting out and you just have your
first data scientist join the company
you don't have that many resources and
you want to grantor two different roles
for two different resources and you
might be inclined to say like oh yes
let's put Alice in the binding for these
two policies that's not best practice if
you stand from day one create a group
called data scientist in this example
and you add Alice to that group once
your users use it in cloud grows it
might be that you have many many more
resources and many more policies and
then you as you are very successful you
hire another data scientist now instead
of finding all of the places where you
have granted Alice permissions you just
add your new hire into that data
scientist group and you know that now
Alice and the new hire will have the
same permission to the same resources
this allows you to manage at scale in
the beginning I talked about the super
powerful set I am policy permission and
as they are so powerful because you can
grant additional policies additional
permissions to other people and to
yourself right remember that like this
it's very powerful it doesn't just limit
you to grant other people access you can
escalate your own privilege which is
makes this very very powerful so
in this hierarchy who do you grant this
permission to and how high in hierarchy
remember the higher in the hierarchy the
more resource they can grant access to
the other one as I mentioned is the act
as service count permission which means
that the user can act and do everything
as the service account can do so the
best practice here is to grant peace on
this service account themselves and not
up in the hierarchy even though you will
be very tempted because it's convenient
at this point in time because later in
time odds are you going to create more
service accounts and now that grant is
automatically granting those users to
act as all of those new service account
that didn't use to exist but now might
have access to on sensitive data so this
is the one case where you really really
want to put your policy on the resource
itself in this case the resource is an
identity which is the service card and
we have seen some of these you know it's
very convenient there's an API it has a
free field say a descriptor and you can
put anything in there
please don't if you have secrets treat
them as secrets put them in a storage
bucket and put the privileges and the
permissions that is appropriate for that
permission for that super secret packet
that you have and not try to code it in
as metadata in other policies
and this leads us to leave a trace say
that you just created your super secret
bucket with all the company's secrets
and someone have access to it and you
don't know who so but default all
changes admin changes to the cloud is
audit Lord so if you do a certain policy
it's going to be logged and you can see
who did that who granted the permission
who changed the policy that is logged
but we don't know by default that you
have a super secret packet and you care
deeply about it so in this I am policy
you can also turn on audit logging and
you can log when someone change in this
case this packet or if someone access it
like who reads this packet because
remember to my super secret pocket if
you want to retain these logs for a
longer period of time you can export
them to cloud storage or to bigquery if
you want to create them there's also
centralized logging systems such as tag
driver that can trigger events and have
things happen when certain logs come in
and I know I'm biased I hope this is big
enough for you to see every week I am
publish all new permissions and roles
and regardless if you use the predefined
roles or the custom roles the best
practice is to visit this page and see
what has changed for two reasons if you
use the predefined roles we will tell
you that this coming week we're going to
add permission to role that you might be
using and like oh that's good to know
because effectively this new permissions
been added into my system the other way
is you use
customers and there's a new API or a new
argument to an API that you really want
to use but your custom rules didn't have
that permission because we just made it
so you have to manually read through
this and say ah I need to add this
permission to my custom rules so that my
developers or my robots or my service
can pick and call this new API or use
these new arguments for this API bring
your organization structure to the cloud
and this is just practical it's you
setting up your company you have thought
hopefully deeply about who reports to
whom and reporting chains and we if
something Braves who do you go to if
your cloud resource arcing doesn't match
that how do you now find the person
responsible to grant you more privilege
something is broken might be broken in
your production system and you need
temporary more access who do you ask if
this match how your company is set up if
that person is your manager that's a
great thing I promise some deep dives
into how we leverage the hierarchy and
this is the first other three examples
so the setup is that we have the Bell
developers and IT admins and we have the
IT admins that have a project and in
this project they have the shared images
their role and the work actually is to
manage these images make sure they're up
to date
they are patched whenever there's a
security incident someone publish
whatever operating system you're using
and your image so you want to grant the
IT admins
the instance admin role so they can
change and update all images under this
project notice this is on the project
itself so as images comes and goes you
don't have to change your policies it's
an important detail and on the project
you also grant the developers image user
roles so that all your developers can
use these images in their projects and
then the developers themselves in their
projects will have the instance admin
and they can then use the images that
the IT admins have created and managed
for them let's take another example
we have the same setup developers IT
admins in this case however it's
different because too we have different
sub networks and some sub networks are
made for developers to play and
experiment and develop we have other
where running your sensitive workload in
production so instead of granting the
developers upon the project level say
use any subject network you want you
will grant them the policy on this sub
network itself that you love for them to
develop on for the developer no change
stable grant the same instance I mean on
their projects in whatever time they
create new projects they can use this
sub network - in this example let's make
the hierarchy a little bit deeper we
have a finance team first of all we have
a company that is larger we start to
have divisions someone in this division
is responsible for managing your budgets
how much can we spend you have sub teams
the different teams can see how much
they spend but not how much the other
teams
and they cannot change their own
allowance
they cannot set their own budget you
want the finance manager to do that so
you will grant the finance manager for
this division the billing account admin
role as high up in the hierarchy as you
can in this example in the division and
again as high up as you can you want to
grant the billing account viewers to the
teams that are affected so team a and
Team B you put those in and what we call
a folder level this allows any project
that Team B creates in the folder to
automatically have the correct policies
instead of having to change and remember
to go back for every project that Team B
creates in the future to add themselves
the permission or the policy to see this
you put it one level up and it's there
and now we growing the company you're
going to be even larger and we see like
oh I'm doing this workflows and I'm you
will find that you have very common
patterns that in this example you create
project you might create an app in game
you want to enable billing you want to
enable some API you want to create
service accounts you want to set some
policies oh that's a lot of work and you
might even want to create custom roles
that you add to these policies all
programmatically of course you can go
out and write your own scripts and do
the exactly the things you want or you
can use the deployment manager it's a
declarative tool that allows you to
focus on what's important to you what
what's the properties of the virtual
machine you want to configure you can
say I want my virtual machine to have
this
memory I wanted this type of CPU and you
actually no longer have to care about
how this happens you go to deployments
man and say this is what I want and
you're setting up these flows and then
you're done it's a fully hosted service
and it's abstract the way that it makes
sense when you're having the same
workflow creating lot of resources at
scale and now we have a story time
so Naveen from Credit Karma is coming up
to tell us about how they leverage I am
and the policies hello everyone my name
is Naveen Guidotti
working for Credit Karma as a senior
security engineer so today I'm here to
share the Credit Karma story of
implementing Identity and Access
Management in the Google cloud platform
so before we jump into the details let
me just give you a brief background on
what we do at Credit Karma so we
actually offer a lot of financial
services to our members like credit
course auto loans personal loans
recommendations etc so our core mission
at Credit Karma is to help our members
make financial progress by utilizing all
these services we have about 80 million
of users who subscribe to create karma
and using these services so it is an
absolute requirement for us to host the
services on a platform that is much
callable efficient and secure so when we
started thinking of migrating to the
Google cloud platform we started off
with some initial goals that will help
secure our infrastructure in a better
way like we wanted to restrict the
access to the GCP console so that we
would allow only a specific set of one
team or individuals accessing the CCP
environment we also wanted to enable
this predator single sign-on process so
that our employees can use that on
enterprise credentials and doesn't need
to use a different ID or anything
and at the same time we wanted to
enforce the small defect authentication
checks and perform the authorization by
implementing the JCB role-based access
controls and we would like to reduce the
burden on our administrators without
manually approaching these identities in
the DC platform and just by automating
it and minimize the human activity in
the GCP environment by leveraging the
disappear organization model so how do
we do this the first step of the process
is authentication we know that GCP is
powered by the cloud identities that can
be created we have the g3 so what we did
was we procured it this way and we
hosted all of our identities in there so
this would also supports the single
sign-on capabilities that can be enabled
via sam'l so we took advantage of that
having this SSO enabled we were able to
delegate all of our authentication
activities to our own interest IDP
platform and that also gave us the
flexibility where you can enforce
additional security restrictions like
enforcing MFA and also making sure the
users are coming from the approved
private networks while accessing these
DCP resources additionally as a best
security practice we wanted to enforce
the limits on the session length of the
users and it has a flexibility for that
so if a user exits the particular
configured limit they will be forced to
rerun decay and identify themselves so
having these pieces in place we were
able to secure the path of accessing the
GCP of our employees now let's take a
look at how this flow works employees in
the Credit Karma side will be accessing
the IDP portal and there will be
authenticating to this IDP portal with
the credentials that are validated
against the director services which is
also hosted in our premises once the
user is successfully a litigator to the
portal our platform is going to generate
a sam'l token and post it onto the gist
field now here this this way which is
acting as an sam'l service provider
verifies the authenticity of the tow cam
by verifying the certificate signature
and identity in it and if everything is
well then G so it is then redirecting
the user
the Google cloud platform by using the
sam'l illustrate so this way we were
able to secure the path of accessing the
Google cloud platform making sure the
user is going through all the security
checks that we enforce along the way now
you have the authenticated user on the
DCP platform and the next part is the
authorization right how do we do the
trick
so in DCP when we are trying to
authorize the users first of all we
would like to enforce the concept of
least privilege and which is by using
the predefined roles or the custom roles
but when do we use this predefined roles
or when do we use this custom roles
let's take an example right if a
developer is requesting an access to one
of the GCB resource like the storage
bucket as Patrick mentioned we will be
assigning them with three different
roles like a storage bucket owner or the
writer or even the admin role so that
the developer can get all the
permissions that he need where he can
update objects inside the bucket or the
deleted objects inside the bucket but
these pre different roles at sometimes
gives you an additional privileges of
setting the IAM policies which means
where he can delegate the access to some
other users as well and we don't want it
to do that because now we wanted to and
force the concept segregation of a
duties because we have a separate team
who is actually performing that access
management activity and this developer
was supposed to only work on the bucket
by updating objects inside the bucket or
deleting or creating the new buckets
so this is where we started creating the
custom roles and creating the custom
roles this very is in the GC you can
just create it from an existing role by
unchecking the permissions that you
don't need or even you can create a
custom role by selecting each and every
granular permission that you do know
that you need and once we have this
exercise done of granular raising the
existing roles or creating all the
required custom roles then we started
off with creating the Google Groups and
as a best practice we always map our
roles to
Google Groups so that we don't need to
manage this access activity at the GCP I
am we don't need to change these
policies every time and we can do that
activity at the Google Groups and we
always try to avoid assigning the CCP
roles to the individuals in the GCP I am
platform and then granting privileges
only on as needed basis this is to make
sure that when we are trying to elevate
the privileges of a developer for a
specific generation we don't want to
keep these privileges on a four hour
basis we wanted to revoke them once the
developers job is done and this is a
concept where we implement this
privilege bracketing and the next thing
is auditing and monitoring we use the
tools like the for city which
continuously keep track of all the
policy changes happening on the GCP I am
and also notify us with any violations
happening there so that we could go back
in there and then fix that this way
again
implementing these concepts and having
this role based access controls in place
we were able to authorize the users who
are accessing the GCP resources and
finally there is PR magicians we use
this disappear organizations to
effectively manage our infrastructure
resources and projects again we followed
the best practices recommended by Google
while implementing these organizations
we started off with creating and parent
or node at the top which represents our
enterprise and then each and every
department in our enterprise is
represented by using the disappea
folders once you get into the
departments as Department owns multiple
applications and the the product we
created a separate project for each and
every application that we hosted in
there
and finally the each and every project
is assigned with all its required DCP
resources so just to sum it up we
followed these best practices where we
delegated our authentication activities
to our IDP platform we use the
predefined roles or the custom roles
most of the time and avoid using the
parameter
rolls and we always mapped these rolls
to the google groups and then enforce
the concept of segregation fugitives and
all of these things together will help
you achieve the least privilege in the
GCP environment so Patrick is going to
share a few more interesting updates in
the next night's thank you so much so I
promised a sneak peek of something we
haven't announced yet you're first to
hear it in this room
I am conditions and we have the some of
the developers built it right here so it
shout out to them so what is I'm
conditions it's a new feature that
allows you to use information from the
client such as what IP address was used
and say oh if you're coming from this IP
address range you can do more powerful
things you can say like if the resource
has a specific pattern like if it starts
with the specific few characters say dev
or prod they're different and you can
combine multiple of these attributes
with boolean expressions and combine it
into very elaborate things so we're
going to dig into some of those examples
so say that you have a trusted device
over your corporate network and you can
now grant a policy to edit a role that
is powerful and say I trust you same
user but if you are working from your
desk you can edit and manage this
resource but the same machine but you
take it home maybe you work from home
it's still your trusted device that the
company gave you you now get a viewer
role you can only view
this resource and if you go into an
internet cafe you still log in it still
you sing the correct correct
credentials and you will not get any
access at all another one that people
are asking for a lot is expiring
policies so you can create a policy that
has a time but it starts at some point
and it ends at any different points so I
said that this is a boolean expression
you can express this in common
expression language it's a relatively
new language that Google have introduced
its optimized to make it easy to
understand to write a reason about your
attributes and we have also announced
access policies which is a different
concept in cloud but these access
policies have something called access
levels these access levels can be
combined with iron conditions so
requests can be classified with
different access levels again depending
on how safe you think this access is and
then you put those in your policies in
your bindings so how would that look
like let's go back to one of my earlier
slides with the you have a storage admin
a powerful role and you have Mike and
admins again but this time I want to
restrict it to only work from a
corporate network our goal and set up
access levels that I define what that
means what this corporate network means
to me
and now this will grant only this
storage I mean this access if they meet
that requirement
so we have some key takeaways we want to
grant roles to group not individual
users use the hierarchy think about
we're in my hierarchy do I want to grant
this permission it's a powerful one this
is weak your one use the role the
correct role type and the correct role
for that matter if you doing a big
production system use the predefined
role or your custom roles don't put any
secrets in your metadata turn on audit
logging for your sensitive workloads
once you grow in scale start thinking
about how to automate to minimize the
human errors and lastly bring your
organization structure to the cloud and
this means both in terms of the
hierarchy it means how you create roles
how do you mean your roles name them
things that make sense for you and your
workloads how do you work in your
company do you have a role that you call
data scientist maybe you create a role
name data scientist maybe have a group
for data scientists suddenly it makes
sense and it's much easier to manage
[Music]